all right so we're going to do a
beginner she was a
drill okay and this one is
uh Lucas coming in with katata Dodi
and then you do whatever technique you
want
okay
uh there's no counters or anything like
that
no variation in there
attack okay
the reason 4G wasn't is different
at the beginning level
from the reason for kihon was
your art
follows an ancient
I don't want to say philosophy I don't
want to say say religion because those
are all tainted today
but let's say an ancient wisdom
that it's a matter of reconciling
what we perceive to be dichotomies
so you have for example yin and yang
I can cook you idiomian tenkon
mind and body the martial and the
spiritual
and you also have kihon ngu waza
this wisdom tradition
Japan cultural and it is observed
throughout history across the globe
but the one that is particular or the
one that is
at the
genealogical Forefront of aikido's
wisdom tradition
is yin yang Theory
yin yang
behind the yin and the young is a
singularity
that's the doubt
what you are trying to do what is set up
conceptually
in this
engagement with dichotomy
is to reconcile them
so that in a way they cease functioning
and when they cease functioning
the Dao will arise
so another dichotomy we have is your
first mind and your second mind or the
ego tripartite and
the god consciousness
what you're trying to do
is bring
a cessation to the functioning of the
ego tripartite the first mind aspect
precisely because its nature is to
experience the world and thus the art
dichotomously
so when you're doing jiuwasa
one of the things that you're trying to
do as you're trying to do throughout
your art is stop
the functioning of the ego tripartite
the stop the functioning of the first
mind aspect allowing the god
consciousness
to manifest
there are some very common ways that the
first mind
manifests in your giwasa training
and prevent you from tapping into the
second mind
contestation
what you're going to do
more commonly than not is push back on
your UK
so even though the the the attack is
prescribed there's going to be enough
human variation
that it won't go exactly as you planned
and you end up
pushing
contesting Yong Yang clashing with your
UK
this is the first mine that's what it
does
and then a second most common way is
especially once you become frustrated
with that first mistake is to start
picking techniques ahead of time before
UK comes in I'm gonna do this one
okay
this is an attachment to form which is
what the first mind does it attaches to
things
and again there's going to be enough
human variation
in the ukemi that sooner or later you're
going to be making the first mistake as
a result of the second mistake I mean
you're going to pick your Technique
beforehand but the way UK came in that
one is now just contesting their energy
so you want to look for those two areas
in your training okay I don't want to
pick techniques
and I don't want to create or generate a
young young Clash contest with my UK
okay
what you can also do here
is stay playful
just like when we were rolling yesterday
don't try to win you don't win gu Wasa
you either
are in your first mind or you're in your
second mind
so to speak
there's no price
so as you stay playful I recommend
getting into trouble
okay
this is the opposite of trying to pick a
technique beforehand you're trying to
stay out of trouble
get yourself in weird situations
okay
and then you'll see from the second mind
the weirdness goes away everything's
perfect
okay
so let's try this okay looking for these
things so if I tell you your your
contesting ukia or I tell you you're
picking the technique beforehand you
know I know what we're doing you know
which mind is functioning okay and then
the solution stay playful get into
trouble okay now that said you don't
want to milk the drill
so you don't want
000 turns
dude this is also a very common thing so
you know you're not supposed to contest
you know you're not supposed to pick the
technique and now you're doing like
two three ten con
like this is not Marshall this is not
realistic this is too much milking of
the drill of the limitations put on UK
do you understand
okay so you can't be turned and turn and
turning no no no
and you cannot give back
or allow UK to gain back their balance
that's not it either okay
and one thing you can do
to make it even more live is no matter
who the UK only in the only the really
good you get is going to just stay
present with the yin yang energy as
you're responding to them
the afraid
him or herself is functioning for the
ego tripartite will try to identify your
Technique because they're attached to
form they will try to pre-identify your
Technique so they can now take the ukimi
that they want to take they oh we do not
get a back break phone you see it and
you should be able to feel their
intention
do you see and allow or work with their
disengaging energy to
them engaged so they don't fall where
they want to fall
Sam you you should not let your UK fall
where they want to fall you can make
their
fear-based intention their ego
tripartite functioning
um become part of your live training
environment by going you're not falling
here you're falling over here okay and
the way you can tell that is they'll
they'll you'll you'll sense the surprise
in them they'll they'll take an inhale
they'll hold their breath their eyes
will bulge they don't fall so well okay
um and so toward that end I recommend
that you go slow don't don't go fast
just train slow speed has nothing to do
with the first or the second line aspect
whether we access it or not okay all
right so let's try this children
do you feel your mind thinking
recognizing certain things
oh oh this oh that whether it be
it didn't work or you see that you're
you're identifying this is all first
mine
these are all ego tripartite okay
once you understand the the the the
delusion that kihon
and you
the dichotomy there
is no yikyo so there is no non EQ so
there's no EQ that didn't happen
so there's no
new thing I have to do
there's no secrets
this is followed by that
but that thinking is not part of it this
is first mind training
okay you already know first mine first
mind's dominating the world mountains
you were raised
in the first mind with the first Mind by
the first mind
it must enter
a different state
that think he's not part of it so those
thoughts you were told in your zazen
training and the thoughts are going to
be coming in because the first mind is
going to keep functioning you see
and what are you told release the
thought release the thought release the
thought release the thought but here
you're not you're trying to use it to
calculate what to do
it doesn't work
so if you pay attention something is
showing up
the hook is stopping
do you see you stop
movement stops it's not fluid because
the mind is not fluid because the first
mind can never be fluid it's always
staccato like
as you get feathered or captured then
you gotta let go then a new one and let
go and a new one like it starts and
stops and so your movement starts and
stops
and so ukia starts and stops you see and
so there's Great Moments where Luca is
just standing there they're not
continually traversing the mat they're
not continually being brought or kept
into kazushi you see it and again that's
milking the drill that can't happen in
real life
okay
so
if you catch yourself thinking
identifying any of those functionings of
the intellect just release it right away
don't try to use it
and pay attention are you is UK movie or
they have they stopped okay this is also
a cue a symptom of the first mind so you
can use it to identify where you're at
okay try it again
okay uh some technical things
uh you're going slower do you see so
there's less inertia
there's less momentum
and additionally
you're okay
does not know what you're going to do so
even here because the ego tripartite
functions through fear and
self-preservation and reification
you're okay even in this dojo
takes little Dives here and there in
kihomasa training do you see and so they
can't do it now
because they can't identify which
technique you're going to do
you see which meant the technique worked
the way you were doing it
in kihon because they were just taking
themselves off balance do you see
well now you slow down so there's less
energy and now Eureka doesn't know where
to go so they're not going to take the
dive so you have to do a fuller range of
motion
so for example I'm watching your kaitan
it's you're too high you never are ever
you're never gaining vertical control of
the head neck area so they're not off
balance you have their head at waist
level that's a three-point stance now
you stopped man you can't get more
stable than that
do you see so you you have to use more
of the vertical plane at this low level
of inertia here so you're going to have
to work your glutes you're going to have
to bend your knees stop being lazy okay
let's try it
okay when you do guas huh
you're not trying to do kihonawasis
you're not trying to pick a form do you
see
don't pick a form okay
you're just
working with energy now
not with construct
so
you don't do
that pins
you see
those are all Coq hole endings ritual
endings in kivon Wasa
you don't do those in giwasa because UK
is just responding to the
energy the yin and yang
of your Technique
and you don't have complete control over
their body and those pins so they should
be continue to keep moving
do you understand that so you you would
have to use one of the other pins that
you've used that are actual pins okay
does that make sense you don't so I
don't want to see you go down and do one
of the keyhone pins because uruka is
just lying there they they should be
able to keep moving
okay
so that means if you want them there you
have to do one of the other pins
okay
going on from this last one so you heard
me say Fuller range of motion
but did you feel the acceleration come
on
okay
that is a form of contestation
what you want to do instead is every
let's let's give a mathematical
perspective to it so here's the Lucas
upright posture and they're gonna go to
a 90 okay so every one of these degrees
you can start manipulating it as you
move it around into the kazishi pattern
it's either the front inward or the back
outward so to speak okay as opposed to
you go straight down and now you gotta
try to accelerate them do you see if you
blend
incrementally with each one of those you
can get the body tilt
that takes them into the kazushi
patterns and you don't have to
accelerate them
okay so look for this also this change
in your tempo
okay in your Technique that too is a
sign that you're functioning from the
first mind okay because you're you're
you the first mind can't make those
adjustments like that it cannot function
at the speed of life it it understands
beginning middle end that's about it
okay and really just beginning to end
okay so let's try it again and not have
to speed up
in fact you can go quite slow and still
keep okay moving still get them in a
kazushi without letting them regain all
that kind of stuff because you just keep
adjusting each one of those degrees into
the kazushi patterns okay let's try it
again
so tell me if this is not true
when you have only access to the first
mind
the Aikido you do is first mind Ikea
the Aikido will not
will not give you access to the second
mind
and first mine Aikido is a
contradictions oxymoronic
there's only really Aikido from the
second mind
so that the techniques are not the
vehicle
for the cessation of the first mind
the first time will
do what it always does
it will take the technique and you'll
experience it through the first mind you
push on what's pushing on you
you intellectualize you Fetter you stop
you accelerate you force it does it'll
never not do that
something to think about
you have let's say you're doing Zen and
you have zazen
and in a way zazen is almost like giwaza
you can't really do zazen until you can
tap into the second line
zazen is almost like a spot check
can you do second mind or not
were you really cultivated
is where Feast is where first mine is
not allowed to function
so in your regimented day
in your strict
Senpai kohai relationship
in your vowel-based Devotion to the
Abbot
in your work
in your dietary prescriptions
if you look at the Buddhist Canon
you have
the sutras
the words of the Buddha the teachings of
the Buddha
then you have a philosophical Canon
commentaries and things like this
but then you have
a monastic code
and when you compare the size of them
the Buddha's words the philosophical
commentaries which is what most of the
West is drawn to
pale in comparison to the size of the
monastic code
why
because it's in that code
that the true catalytic energy necessary
for self-transformation
necessary for learning the skill of
releasing the sensation of the first
mind
it's in the code
it's not in the thing where you need the
first the second mind it's not in that
thing that's just a spot check
you're not going to learn how to
bring a cessation to the first mind
aspect because in G was a because
there's really no penalty for it you
just aren't doing Aikido
so you really have to raise up the other
Dojo practices
not
you're not taking them
for what they truly are
they look in your mind secondary the way
a Westerner looks to the vinaya and goes
oh the main part is the Buddha's
teachings or the philosophical
commentaries and you're like someone
goes why is this if those are the main
parts why is this other part so much
bigger than these other two parts
do you see
why is it Westerner after Westerner
can go to all these meditative
meditation Retreats
etc etc
but can't even live a week under a
monastic rule
why are there certified yoga instructors
vandalizing the electric pumps and I get
called to
right to deal with her vandalism
let me see
put her under a real Guru
and she could not make it
because a lot of the eagle tribe park at
is allowed to continue to function
into imposes in the studio
under Guru
cannot function
ceases to function okay
so same thing here we have a vinaya you
you have to take it much more seriously
we have a guru relationship you have to
take it much more seriously as seriously
as you take it and as much as you engage
in it that is how much
cultivation you're doing in the skill of
releasing
[Music]
that's right
foreign
[Music]
over here
foreign
[Music]